[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم في الحلقه الحاديه عش من تغطيتنا
لاحداث عام
2014 نتوقف اليوم مع شهر نوفمبر وفيه
نستعرض قضيتين رئيسيتين الاولى هي قضيه
صحفي شبكه الجزيره الذين تعتقلهم مصر
والثانيه قضيه تبرئه الرئيس المصري
المخلوع حسني مبارك وقبل التوقف لمناقشه
هذين الموضوعين بشرح وتحليل نستعرض معا
اهم ما شهده شهر نوفمبر من
احداث في شهر نوفمبر يستمر في اليمن العنف
المسلح الذي لا ينهيه اتفاق السلم
والشراكه حيث يواصل الحوثيون عمليات دهم
وملاحقات في صنعاء خاصه ضد افراد عائله
الاحمر تنتج عنها الشباكات المسلحه كما
يشن تنظيم القاعده في اليمن هجمات متقطعه
على قوات الحوثيين والقوات الحكوميه تقع
احداها في اليوم الاول من الشهر في محافظه
الحديده غرب اليمن وتسفر عن مقتل 20 جنديا
حكوميا في الخامس من نوفمبر يصل عدد ضحايا
الاشتباكات بين قوات ثور ليبيا وقوات
خليفه حفتر الى نحو 500 معظمهم يسقطون في
بنغازي وفي الايام التاليه تتواصل المعارك
ولا تزداد الا اشتعالا مع قرب نهايه العام
ويزعم حفتر السيطره على معظم بنغازي وهو
ما ينفيه الثوار في الثام ع من نوفمبر يشن
شابان فلسطينيان هجوما على معبد يهودي في
القدس المحتله يسفر عن مقتل اربعه حاخامات
وشرطي بينما يستشهد الشابان برصاص الامن
الاسرائيلي يدين الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس الحادث لكن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
يقول ان الادانه لا تكفي وبعد ايام تقر
الكنيست الاسرائيلي تشريعا يصف اسرائيل
بانها دوله يهوديه تحت اسم الدوله القوميه
للشعب اليهودي في العش من نوفمبر يتحدث
الرئيس المصري عن انه يدرس عفوا رئاسيا عن
اثنين من صحفي شبكه الجزيره الذين صدر
بحقهم كم بالسجن في وقت سابق من هذا العام
وياتي ذلك بعيد اصدار السيسي قرارا
جمهوريا يتيح له ترحيل سجناء اجانب لقضاء
العقوبه في بلادهم في الخ من نوفمبر تشهد
ضحيه فرجسون الامريكيه مزيدا من
الاحتجاجات على مقتل الشاب الاسود مايكل
براون على يد شرطه رجل شرطه ابيض في الس
16 عشر من اغسطس اثر تبرئه هيئه محلفين
للضابط الابيض وبعد ايام يتكرر المشهد في
منطقه اخرى حيث يقتل شرطي ابيض رجلا اسود
ويرفض القضاء ادانته مما يشعل الاحتجاجات
في مدن امريكيه عده وفي ال8 من الشهر
ترتكب جماعه بوكو حرام في نيجيريا مجزره
اخرى ولكن ضد مصلين في مسجد في مدينه كانو
شمال البلاد يروح ضحيت نحو 120 شخصا
وبينما لا تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها ياتي
الهجوم على المسجد بعد دعوه وجهها الامام
الى الناس لحمل السلاح في وجه الجماعه وفي
ال9 من نوفمبر تصدر محكمه المصريه حكما
صادما وان كان متوقعا على نطاق واسع
بتبرئته ومعاونيه من كل التهام الموجهه
اليهم وبل وتعتبر انه لم يكن هناك وجه
اصلا لاقامه الدعوه ضد مبارك من الاساس
وعلى الفور تخرج مظاهرات احتجاج ضد احكام
البراءه تواجهها قوات الامن كالمعتاد
بالقمع والرصاص وهو ما اعتبره مراقبون
اسدال السيتار على اخر امل لنجاح ثوره
الربيع العربي في
مصر ونتوقف اولا عند ملف تبرئه الرئيس
المصري المخلوع حسي مبارك فقد شهد عام
2014 اخر فصول ما عرفت بمحاكمه القرن وهي
مقاضاه الرئيس المصري المخلوع حسني مبارك
ونجليه ومجموعه من اركان حكمه والتي انتهت
بتبرئته منتهم المرفوعه ضدهم وابرزها قتل
نحو 800 متظاهر ابان ثوره يناير عام
2011 وراى كثيرون في الحكم تتويجا لمسار
قضائي يتهمه المعارضون بالخضوع التام
للسلطه السياسيه الحاليه التي انقلبت
برايهم على ثوره يناير باهداف ورموزها
وصولا لاعاده الاعتبار للعهد
المخلوع
واقول لكم انني كم يبدو الان بعيدا وقريبا
ذلك المشهد الوجه الثمانيني نفسه يتحايل
على الزمن بالمساحيق والصوت الرتيب الذي
لازم المصريين 30 عاما كقدر لم يستجب شباب
الثوره الغاضب في ذلك المساء من شباط
فبراير للاستعطاف بل هزوا الميادين بهتاف
الانتصار ساعه تتنحى ارفع راسك فوق انت
مصري غادر مبارك السلطه وبقيت سلطه مبارك
قيل كثير في رعونه الثوره وعدم قيامها
بالحسم الذي سيظهر من بعد كم كان واجبا
بقدر ما تزايدت الشكوك فيما لو كان ممكنا
فقد كملت السلطه القديمه كالاخ طبوط في
الاعماق وراحت تحرك وادواتها واذهاب غمره
الفرح والغفله بدا مسلسل محاكمه مبارك
التي سميت محاكمه القرن في ايار مايو 2011
احيل حسني مبارك ونجلاه علاء وجمال الى
محكمه الجنايات التي حكمت في حزيران يونيو
2012 على مبارك ووزير داخليته حبيب العدلي
بالسجن المؤبد في قضيه قتل المتظاهرين
وحكمت بانقضاء الدعوه ضد مبارك ونجليه
وحسين سالم في قضيه استغلال النفوذ وتقاد
رشن وتصدير الغاز الى اسرائيل باسعار
زهيده وجلست مصر تشاهد الرجل الذي دانت له
بالولاء القهري سنوات وهو في اقصى درجات
ضعفه الانساني او هكذا اريد له ان يبدو
محمولا على سرير سيختفي السرير فيما بعد
لقد كان اختبارا اخر لعاطفه المصريين مر
الوقت وتغيرت مصر حد الانقلاب وفي يناير
2013 قضت محكمه النقد باعاده محاكمه
الرئيس المخلوع ومن معه لتثبيت حكمها
اندفعت السلطه الجديده في حمله قمع دموي
وبوليسي للمعارضين اختلط فيها الارهاب
بالتظاهر بالتعبير عن الراي في حين تكفل
القضاء بالتغطيه القانونيه فخرج باحكام
اصابت العالم بالذهول كانت عقوبه رفع شعار
او تظاهر تتجاوز عقوبه القتل وربما يحاكم
موتى ويطلب لهم الاعدام فلا عجب من بعد اي
يبرا
القتله
انت كانت ثوره يناير ترحل بعيدا وتوارت
صوره مبارك السجين خلف 40 الف سجين سياسي
دخلوا السجون حكمت المحكمه
حضوريا ببراءته مما نسب اليه ورفعت
الجلسه وحين صدر الحكم بتبرئته في ال9 من
تشرين الثاني نوفمبر الماضي بدا الامر ك
عاده ترتيب لقطعه مقلوبه في لوحه سوداويه
2014 مبارك حر او يكاد يستعد لمغادره سجنه
الصغير ليلاقي خارجه الف مبارك يسوقون مصر
الى سجن
كبير وينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور ايمن
نور رئيس حزب غد الثوره دكتور ايمن بصفتك
احد الفاعلين في ثوره 25 من يناير ماذا
عنا لكم كقوه الثوريه هذا الحكم الصادر عن
القضاء المصري بتبر الرئيس
المخلوع هذا الحكم هو لحظه فارقه بين
زمنين زمن الثوره وزمن الثوره المضاده كان
هناك دائما احساس بالارتياب وان هناك راب
لامل رومانسي ان هذه الثوره يجب وينبغي ان
تنتصر هذه اللحظه التي قضي فيها بعوده
مبارك الى مقعده ولا اقصد شخص مبارك ولكن
قيم مبارك ونظام مبارك كانت هي اللحظه
الفارقه بالنسبه لكل من شارك في ثوره 25
يناير انا بتصور ان العداله في مصر كانت
في تقديري يعني تحطها ظلال كثيفه تحولت
العداله في هذا اليوم الى عداله مطفاه
وتحولت كل الامال حول القصاص لدماء 800 من
ابنائنا ماتوا امامنا وماتوا بوضوح معروف
مين
اللي قتلهم لكن الحقيقه تحولوا من شهداء
الى قتلى وتحولت الثوره من ثوره الى حلم
وتحول رموز وايقونات الثوره الى خونه
وعملاء وتحولت المساله في مسار هو عكس خط
السير الطبيعي الذي كان ينبغي ان تسير فيه
مصر ما بعد ثوره يناير ه هل معنى ذلك ان
هذا الحكم كان انتصارا للثوره المضاده
وازال الستار نهائيا عن ثوره الخامس
من
يناير لا بالعكس انا بتصور انه هو لحظه
فارقه لكنه لحظه يبنى عليها استعاده قيم
ثوره يناير استعاده الاصطفاف الوطني لثوره
يناير وانا بقول الحقيقه ان الصوره او
المشهد السياسي المصري ما قبل
291 2014 مختلف الى حد كبير عنه بعد هذا
التاريخ الكل ادرك ان الخطر قادم ان مبارك
ليس الشخص ولكن مبارك المعنى والقيم
والمنظومه عاده ولا بد من مواجهته واتصور
ان الثوره ستنتصر في النهايه وان هذا
الحكم ربما اعلن في هذا اليوم 29/11 لكنه
بالفعل تحقق وكنا وانا كرجل قانون كنت
متيقن ان هذا الحكم سيصدر منذ
233 201011 عندما تم حفظ التحقيقات في
قضايا الشهداء و وجه قامه الدعوه ضد مبارك
كان واضح ان النائب العام الذي اتخذ هذا
القرار في شهر الثلاثه هو الذي احال نفس
القضيه في شهر خمسه قرار احاله معيب قرار
احاله يساوي البراءه عندما تختزل كل جرائم
نظام مبارك من 30 سنه الى 18 يوم في هذه
كارثه وهذا ما حدث شكرا لك دكتور ايمن نور
رئيس حزب غدي الثوره من
باريس والان نبقى مع مفارقات القضاء
المصري ولكن في ملف صحفي شبكه الجزيره
المعتقلين في مصر ففي اواخر نوفمبر اشار
الرئيس المصري الى احتمال صدور عفو رئاسي
عن اثنين من صحفي الشبكه لكن شيئا لم يحدث
منذ ذلك الحين وكان القضاء المصري قد حكم
على ثلاثه من صحفي شبكه الجزيره بالسجن
لمدد تتراوح من سبعه الى 10 اعوام وجاء
ذلك رغم تاكيد السيسي في حديث لقناه
امريكيه بانه ليس هناك رقابه ولا قيود على
حريه الراي في مصر باي شكل من
الاشكال عام كامل عانت خلاله السلطه
الرابعه في مصر قنوات وصحف اغلقت وصحفيون
قتلوا واخرون اصيبوا وغيرهم سجنوا فقط من
اجل حرصهم على نقل الحقيقه اثر المؤسسات
الاعلاميه التي تضررت كانت شبكه الجزيره
فقد بدا العام واربعه من صحفييها يقبعون
داخل السجون المصريه هم عبد الله الشامي
مراسل الجزيره العربيه الذي اعتقل في ال
14ب عشر من اغسطس
2013 خلال تغطيه مجزره فض اعتصام رابعه
العدويه وبيتر كريست ومحمد فهمي وباهر
محمد صحفيو الجزيره الانجليزيه الذين
اعتقلوا في ال9 من ديسمبر الشامي كانت
النيا تجدد حبسه كل 45 يوما دون توجيه اي
تهمه له وتحتجز في ظروف شديده الصعوبه حتى
قرر الدخول في اضراب عن الطعام بدايه من
منتصف يناير ادى لنقص وزنه عشرات
الكيلوغرامات ونقلته السلطات الى سجن
العقرب شديد الحراسه في شهر مايو مع تدهور
حالته الصحيه وسط معاناه اسرته واخيرا في
السا من يناير قرر النائب العام الافراج
عن الشامي ليخرج منتصرا بعد نحو ع شهور
قضاها داخل السجون اما صحفي الجزيره
الانجليزيه فكانوا اقل حظا من الشام حيث
توشك ماسات على الدخول في عامها الثاني
فرغم لدانه العالميه لاعتقالهم من عواصم
غربيه عده ومنظمات حقوق الانسان الدوليه
ومسانده الصحفيين لهم في كافه بقاع الارض
الا ان السلطات المصريه بدات محاكمتهم في
ا واخر شهر فبراير بتهم غريبه منها دعم
جماعه ارهابيه وتزييف تسجيلات مصوره تهدد
الامن القومي وهي تهم نفاها الزملاء جمله
وتفصيلا وعلى مدار ثمان جلسات استغرقت عده
شهور قدمت النيابه ادله لا علاقه لها
بالقضيه بل كان بعضها مثيرا
لسخريتهم صادم بسجن باهر محمد 10 سنوات وك
من كريست وفهمي سبع سنوات بالاضافه الى
السجن ع سنوات غيابيا على موظفين اخرين في
شبكه الجزيره من جنسيات مختلفه موجه غضب
ودانات عالميه اعقبت الحكم ووقفات
احتجاجيه نظمها الصحفيون لكن لم يفلح ذلك
في تغيير الواقع وقدم المحامون طعنا ضد
الحكم في اغسطس وس تنظر فيه المحكمه في
يناير
2015 لم تتوقف معاناه الزملاء المعتقلين
عند ظروف حبسهم الصعبه فحسب بل تخطتها
لتطال عائلاتهم وحياتهم الشخصيه فبا هر
محمد لم يتمكن من حضور ولاده ابنه هارون
في حين كسى الحزن عائله بيتر جريست جراء
حبسه وزملائه ظلمه الرئيس المصري المؤقت
عدلي منصور كان قد بعث برساله الى عائله
بيتر كريس في استراليا يعرب عن تضامنه
معها والرئيس الحالي عبد الفتاح السيسي
قال عده مرات انه لو كان موجودا في السلطه
لقام بترحيل الصحفيين مؤكدا انه لا يعلق
على احكام القضاء وفي النهايه يبقى هؤلاء
الصحفيون وغيرهم يدفعون ضريبه قول
الحقيقه وتنضم الينا من فينا بارغ تريفي
نائبه مدير المعهد الدولي للصحافه سيده
ترفي كيف كان صدى هذه الاحكام التي اصدرها
القضاء المصري في حق صحفي شبكه الجزيره
سواء في المعهد الدولي للصحافه او في
المنظمات
الدوليه المختصه بحريه
الصحافه معهد الصحافه الدوليه والمنظمات
اخرى الصحفيه شعرت بصدمه كبيره نتيجه
سماعهم هذه الاحكام التي صدرت على
الصحفيين اولا بسبب طريقه اجراء المح
وايضا ثانيا لنوع التهم التي وجهت ضد
الصحفيين مثلا انهم قدموا اخبارا مزوره او
انهم اسعوا الى الامن الوطني وثالثا واهم
شيء
بسبب المده الطويله للعقوبات او الاحكام
اللي صدر ضدهم بين السبعه الى عش سنوات
وهذا طبعا امر غريب ويدعو الى الصدمه
وبالتالي نجد ان هذا امر يدعو الى
اياء وقد بدانا بعمليه في هذا المحد لجمع
بعض
الخبراء في مصر ولحد الان لدينا ثلاث
مستشارين من الخبراء لتقييم وضع حريه
الصحافه في مصر ولتقييم ما يمكن ان يفعله
المجتمع الدولي لمعالجه هذا الوضع لان
هناك قلق شديد حول ما يحصل في مصر الى اي
حد ربما اعتبرت هذه القضيه بالنسبه لكم
ظاهره يقتضي
ربما التعمق اكثر في بحثها وبحث اسبابها
وم منها تكون منطلقا ل تسليط الضوء على
واقع الصحافه في بلدان الربيع
العربي
اعتقد ان هذا موضوع معقد ومهم للغايه فيما
يتعرق موقف حكومه السيسي ازاء حريه
الصحافه ف في بدايه السنه الحكومه اصدرت
دستورا جديدا يحتوي ضمانات قويه لحريه
الصحافه ولكن الحكومه لحد الان لم تطبق
هذه الضمانات بل هي بعيده عن ذلك جدا
والجانب الصعب في هذا السلوك الحالي
لحكومه مصر ازاء الصحفيين والاحكام التي
صرت على الصحفيين الثلاثه من الجزيره وعدد
اخر من الصحفيين
المحليين جرى التركيز عليه من قبل الامم
المتحده ايضا اثناء مراجعتهم لحقوق وضع
حقوق الانسان في مصر وان مجلس حقوق
الانسان عبر عن قلق شديد ازاء ما يحصل في
مصر كما ان الوفد المصري
استق حصل على 300 توصيه الكثير منها تتعلق
بحريه الصحافه في مصر
كان لافتا ان صحفي شبكه
الجزيره
بعد ثوره ال5 يناير اعتبروا ابطالا في مصر
نظرا للمستوى المهني الذي غطوا به هذا
الحدث الكبير ولكن بعد بعدما انتصر
الانقلاب وجدوا انفسهم وراء القضبان رغم
انهم كانوا يؤدون دورهم بنفس يعني المستوى
بنفس المستوى المهنيه كيف تفهمين
ذلك
اعتقد
ان ما بدات الجزيره بالعمل في مصر اثناء
فتره
مبارك كانت بالنسبه لكثير المصريين امرا
جديدا وطريقه جديده لتغطيه الاخبار وطريقه
شديده او عدائيه بمعنى انها تطرح اسئله
صعبه وبالتالي فان كثير من الناس في مصر
كان يحبونها ويقدرونها
واعتقد انه بعد الثوره وخاصه بعد الاطاحه
بالرئيس
مرسي الحكومه حكومه الرئيس
السسي
شعرت بان تغطيه الجزيره
قد قد تكون داعمه الى حد كبير ليس واعتقاد
لحكومه السيسي بل ايضا داعمه ايضا
للمعارضه اي والاخوان المسلمين وهي حركه
حكومه السيسي قررت منعها وبالتالي اعتقد
هذا هو السبب ان الجزيره اصبحت هدفا
يستهدف في مصر واننا نعتقد ان الموقف ازاء
الجزيره بشكل عام طبعا هذا يشمل صحفيين
اخرين الذين يبدون قدرا كبيرا هذا الموقف
يبين ان الحكومه غير ديمقراطيه وانها لا
تقبل اي نوع من الانتقادات ضدها ولا تقبل
لوسائل الاعلام ان تعبر عن اراء تختلف عن
الحكومه نعم طبعا كما تعلمين ويعلم الساده
المشاهدون نحن قمنا بواجبنا ك قناه
اعلاميه تنقل
الاحداث كما هي وبعمق الذي تقتضيه اهميه
هذه الاحداث شكرا لك على كل حال السيده
بربره تريفي نائبه مدير المعهد الدولي
للصحافه من
فينا ونتابع استعراضنا لاحداث شهر نوفمبر
الذي شهد تصعيدا خطيرا في نشاطات جماعه
بوكو حرام التي كانت من ضمن احداث اخرى
عده حيرت افكار المتابعين الذين لم يجدوا
لها تفسيرا مناسبا حتى اللحظه فقد قامت
الجماعه التي تتهم بانها جماعه الاسلاميه
بمهاجمه مسجد في مدينه كانو شمال
نيجيريا
في شهر يوليو تموز من هذه السنه تظاهر
المئات من الشبان النيجيريين امام المقرات
الحكوميه بالعاصمه ابوجه وكان مطلبهم هو
حث الحكومه على العمل لاعاده نحو 200 فتاه
تم احتجازهن من قبل جماعه اهل السنه
للدعوه والجهات المعروفه ببوك حرام وقد
تفعل الملايين في انحاء العالم مع هذه
المطالب بعد ان وجد الشباب المنظمون لهذه
الحمله في و التواصل الاجتماعي اداه
لايصال رايهم وخصوصا في الدول الغربيه
التي اصدرت العديد من حكوماتها بيانات
تتهد بمساعده نيجيريا في مواجهه
الجماعه وزادت الولايات المتحده باعلان
البيت الابيض ارسال 80 جنديا وطائرات بدون
طيار للتمركز في العاصمه الشاديه ان جمينه
وهي المنطقه الاقرب لمراكز نشاطات الجماعه
بشمال شرق نيجريا اما فرنسا فقد عقد
رئيسها في باريس قمه استثنائيه جمع حوله
فيها رؤساء نيجيريا والدول المحاذيه
للمنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه منها لتنسيق
جهودهم لمحاربه الجماعه وقال ان قوات
بلاده المنتشره في الساحل ستشارك في هذا
الجهد ايضا ولكن هذا لم يوقف نشاطات بوكو
حرام بل استطاعت خلال النصف الثاني من هذه
السنه تكبيد الجيش النيجير خسائر في
الارواح والمعدات
واستولت على عده مدن ووسعت من نشاطات الى
الكاميرون المجاوره حيث اشتبك الجيش
الكاميروني مع مسلحي الجماعه في عدد من
المدن الحدوديه مع نيجيريا ووصل عدد
النازحين واللاجئين من جراء الصراع الى
نحو مليون شخص حسب احصاءات الامم المتحده
ثم اعلنت الحكومه النيجيريه انها تلقت
وعدا من ممثلين للجماعه خلال مفاوضات عقدت
في العاصمه الشاديه ان جمينه باطلاق سراح
الفتيات المحتجزات وردت الجماعه بنفي
التفاوض مع الح الحكومه وان الفتيات قد
اسلمن وتم
تزويجهن تبنت جماعه بوكو حرام خلال هذه
السنه عده تفجيرات بعضها نفذ في العاصمه
ابوجه وقد استهدفت الجماعه بهجمات مراكز
تابعه للشرطه والجيش كما استهدفت مواقع
مدنيه مكتظه
بالسكان هذا ما وقع عام 2009 فالقتل
مواطنون نيجيريون يسكنون مدينه ميدغري في
شمال شرقي البلاد وتتهم المنظمات الحقوقيه
قوات الامن النيجيريه من الجيش والشرطه
بممارسه مثل هذه الانتهاكات ضد المواطنين
الابرياء طوال فتره هذا الصراع التي بلغت
نحو خمس سنوات فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
ابوجه والى هنا ينتهي مشاهدينا استعراضنا
واياكم لابرز احداث شهر نوفمبر عام 2014
في الغد بحول الله نتوقف مع احداث شهر
ديسمبر الى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]
ا h